تهانينا أه سؤالي الأول ،
ما هو شعورك أن تكون الرجل
الذي وقع مع الرجل الذي
أراده بقية العالم.
دائمًا ما
يكون لدينا هذا الطموح الكبير للغاية
، فالنادي هو
الذهاب إلى أعلى مستوى ،
لذلك
لدينا اليوم أفضل ستة لاعبين من
جوائز الكرة الذهبية ، أعني أنني أعني حقًا أن
ليو الرائع نفسه قال
إنه حدث بسرعة كبيرة
وكانت هناك بعض الأشياء الصعبة
لكنهم  تم العمل عليها ، لذلك بالنسبة للأشخاص
الذين يتساءلون عن كيفية نجاحك في
العمل ، هل يتناسب مع القواعد ،
ما رأيك أنه سار
سريعًا في اليوم الذي قرر فيه
مع برشلونة إيقافك ،
نعلم أننا بدأنا الاتصال
ونعرف أن  لقد قلت سابقًا أنك تعلم
أن الرغبة الكبيرة بين الطرفين
كانت
موجودة وكانت سريعة جدًا ولهذا السبب
تحقق
ذلك وقبل أن نفعل أي شيء
نأخذ كل شيء يمكننا القيام به أو
لا.  أنا بصراحة
شاركت في هذا الأمر
وقلنا نعم يمكننا تحقيق ذلك من
الناحية المالية ، أعني أنه من
الرائع أن يكون لدينا أفضل لاعب في
العالم في باريس وجيرما خلال
الأيام الثلاثة الماضية ، وهو أمر
لا يصدق المكالمات التي
وردت من شركاء تجاريين
غير مؤمنين  أعني بصراحة
أنني لم أتوقع ذلك كثيرًا ، أعني أنني أعلم
أنه كان حقًا أنت حقًا إنه فوضوي
ولكنك تعلم أننا
اشترينا دائمًا هدفًا عاليًا جدًا
لفريقي ولكن هذا كان أعلى من هدفنا
أن نكون صادقين رائعًا ، هل يمكنك البدء
لتقدير التأثير
الذي سيحدثه وجود ليون أو ميسي في باريس
سان جيرمان
على هذا النادي ،
فقد حدث بالفعل في آخر 48 ساعة ،
أعني أنني لن أرى الأرقام
حتى الرعاة الذين يقدمون لنا
اليوم ، أعني أنه شيء لا يصدق
بصراحة ، إذا رأيت أيضًا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بنا
الأسبوع الماضي ، كنا أحد
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي 35 مليونًا اليوم ، نحن 42
مليونًا ، أعني حتى أقل من ثلاثة أيام ،
أعني أن هذا مذهل ، أعني بالنسبة لنا
إنه
كذلك  أعلم أن الفرصة الرائعة التي قدمتها
في العامين الماضيين كانت أزمة
مرغوبة ، لكنني أؤمن بشيء واحد ، كل
أزمة هي فرصة ، ونحن نوقع أربعة
لاعبين مجانًا وقيمة هؤلاء
الأربعة بالإضافة إلى
حكيمي ، أعني زيادة أصول
النادي إلى ما يقرب من ثلاثة  مليار ، لذا فهو
رائع بصراحة ، أعني أن الناس لا
يدركون هذا ، فهم لا يعرفون ذلك ، لكن
أعتقد أنهم يجب أن يعرفوا من هو
قدرتنا المالية في الواقع ،
فما الذي حددته
لينور ميسي
كمهمته لأنه لا يوجد أي مكان لأي  أعذار
بعد
الآن لنكون صادقين ، لم نضع أي
مهام تعرف سببها لأنه اشترى
المهمة لنفسه
من خلال مؤتمره الصحفي لبرشلونة ،
قال إنه فاز بواحدة وذهب
للألقاب ورأينا أنني كنت العام الماضي لم يكن
سعيدًا لأنه  تريد الفوز ، إنه
فائز ، إنه يفكر فقط في كرة
القدم وهذا ما أردته
فقط أن يكون ليو كما
هو داخل الملعب وخارجه هذا ما
نريده.